[Musique]
people are fascinated by Rob kind of man
creating life in his own image it's also
legalizedable form of
slavery
on voit que après la guerre les Japonais
sont omnibilés par l'AT parce qu'il a
ils ont eu de bombes
atomiques
nous avons
encore cette vieille peur le robot si on
le laisse un peu trop venir parmi nous
peutêtre Vail vouloir prendre notre
place
[Musique]
le jouer robot ne se limite pas une
boîte en fer blanc munie d'un mécanisme
simple et peint de couleur vive c'est un
jouet qui fait appel à la formidable
culture de la science-fiction une
culture où sont projetés les rêves et
les peurs de l'humanité pour raconter
cet objet il nous faut voyager ai bien
dans l'histoire et la littérature que le
cinéma et les sences il nous faut
rencontrer des chercheurs qui sont
restés de grands enfants des
collectionneurs qui se r scientifique
des cinéphiles qui s'imaginent
visionnaire cette histoire pourrait
commencer à 6h du matin un dimanche à
Paris il est ne en boîte il a son
antenne d'origine ce qui est rarissime
en fait l'anten d'origine est très
fragile très très rare
donc c'est pour ça que ça fait puis le
succès c'est que c'est sa couleur aussi
il a une superbe couleur sa boîte est en
parfait état la boîte est hyper rare en
général la boîte double souvent la la
valeur d'un d'un jouet non cel celui-là
est assez courant celui-là est beaucoup
plus rare
voilà j'ai acheté un petit un petit
jouet un robot des années 60 le connais
ça c'est des jouets en fait qui ont été
vendu par des des distributeurs
américains et voilà un petit robot aussi
très très très très cool des années 60
j'achète ici tout ce qui est mine Japan
pour le vendre au japonais parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de Japonais qui cherchent à
retrouver leur leur souvenir d'enfance
mais ils ont du mal parce que parce qu'
ils ont tout
jeté mais la boîte est belle desétat en
plus le premier robot japonais est quand
même d'avantgerre faut voir c'est c'est
vraiment très beau hein si vous replacez
ça dans les années 40 jusqu'à 55 c'est
très en avance pour son temps les
Japonais ont fait vraiment les premiers
jouets à pile puisqueavant ça c'était
surtout des jouets mécaniques ou à
friction ou à remonter donc à clé C les
Allemands qui étaient leaders dans le
marché et eu eux ont vraiment
révolutionné le marché avec justement
ces jouets qui euh qui fonctionnaient
avec des batteries qui fumaient qui
faisait des lumières dans tous les sens
et c'est ça en fait que Al fait la la la
force du Japon en ce qui concerne le
marché du joueur le Japon est au cœur de
l'histoire du jouet robot c'est là
queaprès la Seconde Guerre mondiale ont
été fabriqués pour les États-Unis des
milliers de jouets dérivés de
l'imaginaire des films ou encore des
rêves suscités par la conquête de
l'espace lorsquil s'agit de raconter
l'histoire des jouets au Japon personne
n'égale monsieur
kitar expert mialement reconnu dans le
domaine des
jouets
注れ
193年3年 made OC
Japan はの
の
し た 缶 だ と用 し
てのちゃ を 作っ て輸
て は だ と か ま行 機 だ と か そして ね この ロボット と いう
も これ も ね
す べき
[Applaudissements]
特にur St dans ses entrepôts nous
partirons à leur recherche un peu plus
tard世 1950 年 から
年 です ね作っ
た工工含める 100以 あっ い
ますの
PAM
[Musique]
des
an
ー今力 の が キラクター の魅力 でちゃ売る に な てき たそう
いうちゃ売方 の変化
ね
[Musique]
プック 年代
うわっわわ のタート が 28号 と か
ム
のちゃ最 な のちゃ の歴史 の
た ね フトビニ の と プラック
と
le développement des robots au Japon
serait donc lié à la culture des bandes
de ciné manga et à le exploitation en
dessin anim diffus à la télé à la source
de cet
a am et son légendaire as prier mangaccs
des
anné50のた新くめる要 ん です
が漫画非常 に簡単 です え髪 とペ が あれば能 ある 人 がすぐ く こと
が できるえ その 中 でえ まず あの私 の父親 で ある
が非常 に 新しい 感 を 持っ た 漫画 を たく 書い た ん です ね
アストボー は日本 で 1最初 にテレビ で 放送 さ れ た アニーョ な ん
ですれ が 61 年 に日本 で 最初 にアメョ に なっ た の です に
ポンー屋さ屋さ
ンて の マダング を 作 ん です ねれ が本
のロボット の アニメショ の 最初 の マーンダング
[Musique]
な
le lien existant entre bande dessiné
produit dérivés et succès des robots est
évident chez Bandai énorme producteur de
jouet japonais pa du tamagi des Pokémon
Gundam et autr power
rangersちら の です ね こちら が 1964 年 に 初めてラクター
の と し
[Musique]
てリモン付
193常
200年カ
LED
[Musique]
Rangers cycl les figurines Power Rangers
trans à volé
en れる と ん もミック
も非常 な てる と思う ん
もつー
にり doit doit avoir trois qualités il
doit être
simple peu figuratif et non mécanique
exactement l'antirobot quoi puisque
simple c'est pas simple un robot ça a
des fonctions peu figuratif c'est hyper
figuratif et non mécanique et c'est
essentiellement mécanique c'est dans le
développement de l'enfant et en quoi
l'enfant se porte sur l'objet l'objet
joué pour se séparer de la relation avec
sa mère de son père de sa grand-mère
l'objet est intermédiaire il est
transition objet transitionnel entre
dans le fond la relation avec les
humains et le jeu les garçons et les
filles partent à la conquête de leur
sexe grâce au jouet et c'est vrai que
vers 4 ou 5 ans l'identification
sexuelle est représentée par le jeu et
les jouets et quand je dis 45 ans c'est
qu'à partir de 4 ans on est à la facee
des scénaris on invente on joue à
plusieurs au début on joue seul le jouet
est support du jeu qui va nous permettre
de jouer de manière sexuée le le robot
va va effectuer des des gestes des des
moments que le petit garçon ne peut pas
réaliser le robot c'est propulsé une
force un pouvoir qu'on a pas c'est le
robot quand je serai grand je serai un
robot le dxaz force cyclone un robot qui
déclenche des tempêtes et propulse des
sphes d'un puissance phénoménale le
dxazord un robot géant qui pousse des CR
redoutables et possède une panoplie
d'armes super puissante un robot au
pouvoir exceptionnel un avion lancemile
qui se transforme en robot monstre
d'acier il tire réellement des missiles
et attaque l'ennemi une puissance de feu
incroyable mission accomplie mission
[Musique]
accomplie le jouet robot s'appuie sur
l'imaginaire initié par la science le
mythe du robot tout-puissant puise ses
racines dans les avancées technologiques
mais aussi et surtout dans les rêves des
auteurs de science-fiction
en 1920 l'auteur t Carel CAPEC écrit un
drame utopiste l'histoire d'un ingénieur
qui invente une machine capable de
remplacer l'homme dans l'exécution des
tâches pénibles ces androïdes se
rebellent contre leurs géniteurs et
exterminent l'espèce humaine pour nommer
ces créatures CAPEC cré un nouveau mot à
partir du mot check robota signifiant
travail forcé c'est ainsi qui né le mot
robot Dieu a créé l'homme à son image du
moment où l'homme crée une machine à son
image c'est le docteur frensin il se
prend pour pour Dieu normalement selon
les religions occidentales il doit être
puni quand on regarde l'image du robot
euh dans la littérature ou des créatures
artificielles dans la littérature on va
s'apercevoir qu'il y a finalement un
petit peu toujours le même genre
d'histoire qui est qui est redite et
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut remonter
à aux bases même de de notre
civilisation à la manière dont le dieu
de la Genèse s'y prend pour créer euh
Adam il va d'abord employer une
technique qui est une technique humaine
qui est la la céramique et puis il va
l'animer ensuite avec une technique
divine et donc cette espèce de création
en deux temps une technique humaine et
une technique divine elle est assez euh
intéressante quand on la compare à la
manière dont l'homme se se comprend
peut-être par rapport aux machines qui
construit c'estàdire que finalement ce
qu'on voit dans ce dans ce motif c'est
le fait que à un moment donné dans son
histoire l'homme va considérer que il
est une machine une machine la plus
sophistiquée de son époque plus quelque
chose qui justement il n'est pas pas
capable de construire qui qui constitue
la technique
[Musique]
divine on est en plein siècle des
Lumières et à ce moment-là et bien on va
les réaliser les
automates un personnage central quand
même dans toute cette histoire c'est
Jacques vacanson vacanson en son temps a
été l'homme des automates l'automate à
mon avis qui est le plus intéressant
c'est le joueur de Flut il joue de la
flute traversière avec son souffle et
avec ses doigts cela veut dire que V
cananson pour créer son androïde a
d'abord appris à jouer de la flute ce
qu'on voit c'est que le travail du
créateur
d'automate consiste d'abord à analyser
complètement les gestes et de décomposer
ces mouvements ces gestes en élément
premier
vosansçon lorsque on va lui demander
d'être inspecteur des manufactures dans
les années 1750 et bien il va mettre à
profit son savoir-faire de constructeur
d'automate pour réaliser les premières
machines automatiques si on essayait de
de rassembler cette aventure de
l'automate je dirais d'abord
effectivement il est dans la tête c'est
un rêve il se concrétise sur je crois au
siècle des Lumières où il a forme
humaine au 19e siècle il va s'éclater
c'estàd qu'on va en trouver l'aspect
gestuel dans les usines ce seront les
machines outil puis les automates
programmables tous les éléments sont là
mais il faudra attendre encore le 20e
siècle pour voir se recomposer cet
ensemble avec de nouveau des androïdes
et on va retrouver finalement cette
unité que l'on avait dans l'umide
primitif et que l'on avait perdu avec
l'air
industrielle ces machines douées
d'intelligence et de volonté qui agripe
déplace usine contrôle ont évincé
l'homme autour de ce monstre fascinant
de puissance et de volonté il n'y a plus
rien qu'un monde de
métal les voici eux les servants du
monstre ils savent que la machine n'est
pas intelligente
qu'elle n'a de volonté que celle des
réflexes que l'homme lui a donné
pourtant c'est ainsi que la plupart du
temps la presse à grand tirage présente
l'automatisation du travail il faut
reconnaître que c'est facile et quees
installations se prêtent à une mise en
scène
impressionnante le robot est donc devenu
une réalité ancré dans notre quotidien
il peut devenir une menace le point de
Magnus dur comme l'acier atteint le
robot au point le plus vulnérable
poussez-vous les
enfants il il invincu les PA Rob de ses
mains nues qui êtes-vous
Magnus nous sommes dans l'incroyable
métropole de nordam dans les années 4000
Magnus est le seul à pouvoir s'opposer à
la destruction de la race humaine par
les robots créés par l'homme laissez-moi
machine mais corrompu laissez-moi nous
avons nos ordres vous devez venir avec
nous lorsque pigmon a donné vie à sa
statue devenant ainsi l'ancêtre des
créateurs de robots ou d'androïdes il a
fondé avec elle une véritable
dynastie l'être artificielle n'inspirait
pas alors la crainte et l'inquiétude
qu'on peut ressentir aujourd'hui des
monstres de
métal c'est notre peur de la machine qui
remonte on a créé la machine il y a pas
longtemps c'est le 19e siècle la
cybernétique l'informatique ça date de05
c'est pas vieux tout
ça間 と の 関わり な ん です けど も ま私た はう小さい 頃
からの まア と か ね でそう いう私 は て育 ます から非常 に こう達
的 な
感の機械 で
ある な の か も しれ ない ん です けど に 心 が あ るってい意外
と 思 ん です よ ねそう いう 意味 で は あの こう いっ た 機 に
も です ね 心 が 宿っ て いる いう 風 に あの 私たち は非常 に
こう な もの と し て 捉えるそう いっ た とろ
ます ま
いう感持る なる と ねれ
とく欧 の 方々 はの
はちょっとえる 描方 が多 けどはッ に し て どんな 感想 持れ ます か言
ます と や ちょっと 怖い と です ねそう いう ま感 る
う て に私 がう て われる ん です か まし た っぱり あの ま小さい
頃 からそう いう ット が 襲っ てく画 なんか も随分
っぱ見
な ま
の非常み感達 の よ な ボット いう
て た は
です prog to you a bu from our unitadi and
gent
weadioiono to give latest on
amazen ladies and gent i something is
Happ
[Musique]
depuis King Kong en passant par
Frankenstein et cetera le monstre est
quelqu'un de différent et
progressivement le monstre classique
disparaît en gros le robot va le
remplacer dans l'État moderne parce que
il s'est passé quelque chose de
formidable avec la guerre c'est que pour
briser les codes allemands on inventé la
machine de turinge donc on a inventé
l'ordinateur plus l'ordinateur s'est
réduit plus on se dit en fin de compte
on peut doter une machine d'un esprit
des robots gigantesques exécuteur des
basses œuvres d'une civilisation
dégadante James wall quand fr Einstein
c'est un M homosexuel donc il utilise
frankinstein pour montrer qu'on peut
être différent mais quelqu'un de bien
quand même mais que l'apparence est
affreuse mais qu'il faut regarder
au-delà de l'apparence je vous appelle
colem en fait quand le robot est méchant
c'est toujours King Kong je m'explique
c'est que l'image de King con portant
une Pau
femme qui veut violer plus tard qui est
sur 6000 affiches elle a servi pour les
singes elle a servi pour les robots elle
a servi pour les monstres de l'espace et
a l'idée c'est d'avoir une créature la
plus laide possible qui menace une pure
vierge qui est d'ailleurs très
déshabillée généralement et le monstre
là c'est un
[Musique]
robot of lock Martin would was actually
inside the rubber suit that they used
now the rubber suit had stitching in the
front in the back and the sides they had
different suits for every shot or angle
if he was walking away from you it would
be stitched in the front and vice versa
this is gord's big head when he would
get mad his head would tilt down and
then his visor would lift up and then
that you would have that that light that
heat beam and of course he would destroy
you which was always fun g was a man of
very few words but a man of action
ntheless got no mouth but he's a great
guy here we have uh Maria from Fritz
Lang's production of Metropolis back in
1926 but she is very German Art Deco 20s
and you really look at her face and her
little her little hat there she looks
almost exactly like C3PO well this this
would be here called his his heart box
actually this guy looks like he has
arhymia but it's supposed to be like a
like
a heartbeat and we know that the robot
indeed does have a heart and uh he's a
good guy and then you have these
programming uh buttons underneath him
they do various things for the robot uh
what exactly I couldn't tell you I mean
if I hit the alpha button i don't know
does he sing the alphabet song maybe
there's an engineer somewhere who
actually knows what these mean I not
progr for babysitting i restored this
robot uh of course I restored the
original r the robot a lot of the other
robots um were
destroyed over the years and there was
nothing to restore like you'll show g
from the day the stood still he was AAM
suit so there was nothing to restore he
disintegrated there was Maria from
Metropolis she got bombed during the
Blitz literally but for years before the
prop thing started the studios were
forget it I mean this was in the
Junkyard at Fox literally there was no
interest in IT same with Robie again
this was in the 70s when uh props was
not a i mean studios throwing away props
today their treasure I mean course is
Rob the robot from the 1956 film
forbidden Planet this again is the most
famous and adored movie robot of all
time Ching in the robot able to produce
on order 10 tons of le or a slinky
evening g you know so he he's just a
movie star i mean almost 50 years and he
he's still in St I meanhe of it for a
movie prop and what movie prop if you
think about it ever gets their own crit
in thening of forbidden Planet it says
and introducing Robbie the
robot the original was made out of a uh
very early ABS thermalm plastic called
royalite which they us for suitcases of
the day he was made out of an orange
plastic and the only orange that you see
here is actually behind his eyes here
that was the only part that wasn't
painted the gun netal Gray must be the
loveliest softest thing you've ever made
for me and fit in all the right places
with lots and lots of star sappires
ifi and human the robot didn't make it
just another walking and and it took off
in the 50s in terms of toys and knocks i
mean everything had two loops and a big
dome head and so forth i mean everything
was the
robot les produits drivés ont toujours
représenté une économie
ente à la sortie de Planète interdite
des milliers de petits robis ont donc
envahi les foyers américains et ils
étaient tous produits au Japon bonjour
bienvenue dans notre galerie on va
commencer par la période de Planète
interdite le Robi il y a il y a quelques
robots qui ont été faits avant même même
un petit peu avant guerre et par les
Japonais après guerre mais c'est la
période du du Robi où ça commence ça a
vraiment prix quoi il y en a qui sont à
pile télécommandé il y en a qui sont à
clé ça c'est en vrai c'est en vérité
c'est la forme d'un RBY mais on
l'appelle pas le Robby pour pas problème
de droit il y a des variantes de de ce
robot où il y a que le bas qui se
ressemble et le haut il y en a avec la
tête de robot il avec la tête de
l'astronaute c'est les mêmes formes ça
veut dire c'est le même moule qu'est-ce
qui change ce qui change c'est c'est
c'est les accessoires alors celui-là
c'est le premier avec les bras coutchou
mais ça pas ça a pas marché très
longtemps parce que les bras il
partaient il partaient tout de suite ah
alors après ils ont fait avec les bras
en on tole dans les années 60 quand ils
ont ils ont compris le truc bah ils
mettent ils font carrément en plastique
dur mais ça c'est très recherché avec
les bras en caoutcho parce que ils ont
pas fait une grande quantité voilà ça
c'est l'histoire des robis après c'est
la période des
astronautes c'est la période la conquête
de l'espace la lune et tout ce tout
alors pour faire rêver les enfants ils
ont construit ils sont fabriqué des
petits des petits Astros ils ont aussi
fait beaucoup de de fusées des petites
voitures comme ça quand vous regardez
les boîtes c'est toujours dans le même
esprit regardez c'est SP
car il y a même des pistolets de
l'espace quand il ont commencé à
s'intéresser à tout ce qui est fusée
aussi ça a commencé comme ça et ça a
fini comme
[Musique]
ça a ça aussi des fois il veut
pas parce que quand on l' pas on l'a pas
on l'a pas fait marcher pendant quel un
bout de temps les contacts s'oxyde
toujours les faire marcher au moins une
fois tous les TR mois un truc comme
ça aujourd'hui de vieux rêves mécaniques
deviennent
réalité de l'autom
la MA de la machine transf la machine
électonique calculatrice et logicienne
la route est longue mais le désir reste
le même décharger l'homme du fardeau de
son travail sur des
méc la SCI et les rêv qui lu sontiment
l'industrie du jouet la récipro est vra
l' d'enfant des scientifi aelle une
incidence sur leur
travail が漫画 で 書かれ た に です ねえ 作者 の
は この お話 の代 は 2003 年 だ と いう 風 に 決め た ん です
ねえ です から 実際 2003 年 が 来 た 時 に ロボット の 開発者
た はても 焦っ た ん です 自分 たち が もっと何 と か し なきゃ
いけ ない と え と 同じ 世界 を 作ん なきゃ いけ ない と いう
気持ち がのすごくえ て き て それ で 余計
に開 仕 が です ね
作れ と いう 言れ まし て です ね 1年間
[Musique]
1ぐット も な ところ で やっぱり い て 役 に 立っ て くれる よ な
もの 私たち と 同じ よ な
て機械
が常う との境
るやろ
ことなり あの ザイ の で 時間 を かけ
てみ で 討 し た あの デザイ な ん です けどまり と か口
がっきりうえる より もむ
なんかうり と し て て 見え
ない に ねイメー が ねき やすい ん
です一番最初 の ボッ トっ て いう の は です
ねえ つまり本足 だけ で く ロボット が 1番
最初本足 で 歩く と いう その 部分 の 機能 は まだまだ あの 実用 的
な も て いう の は でき て い なかっ た ん です ね で しっ て
その 下半身 の その本足 で 動 分 を にやろ と いう ことの
ボット に 作っ た ん です
conwa ha connwa
thee
mas
ASO
AK
a
a 아 아ga than
[Musique]
調 n'est pas encore tout à fait
opérationnel et encore moins
commercialisé et quelle place le robot
peut-il trouver aujourd'hui dans notre
quotidien Aujourd'hui le robot est
essentiellement le robot commercialisé
est essentiellement ludique avec un fort
aspect pédagogique comme on voit là on
va s'amuser mais on va apprendre tout ce
qui est mécanique électronique
informatique et on a quelques robots
utile donc c'est le RC 3000 qui se
promène dans le magasin qui va être
capable de nettoyer c'est le tomower
d'électroluxe le le robot tondeuse ce
qui va y avoir dans les prochaines
années c'est déjà la on va dire la
démocratisation du robot on considère
que le marché du robot va être supérieur
au marché de l'informatique à terme donc
ça va vraiment exploser avec des robots
qui vont faire des petites tâches comme
ça relativement simple qui vont baisser
en prix et qui vont exploser en en
volume et de l'autre côté on va avoir ce
qu'on va appeler les compagnons robot
robotique comme l'IBO qui vont être de
plus en plus présents euh dans les
foyers et troisème point c'est le côté
robotique mais directement dans l'objet
c'est-à-dire ce qu'on voit déjà
actuellement les voitures qui ont des
aspects robotique à l'intérieur de la
voiture donc ça va pas être un robot
spécifiquement mais plutôt adapté
intégré dans un
objet donc ce robot c'est l'IER one on
va utiliser un ordinateur portable pour
le commander c'est-à-dire toute entre
guillemets l'intelligence du robot est
dans l'ordinateur portable et donc qui
permet d'avoir un robot de de 80 cm pour
pas trop cher et d'autre part d'avoir
vraiment la puissance d'un ordinateur
dans un robot on peut lui monter une
pince on peut lui rajouter des des
décapteurs
supplémentaires et on peut le faire
réagir un objet par exemple quand il
reconnaît un objet quand il reconnaît
une personne on peut le faire réagir
danser lancer une
vidéo suivre la personne s'éloigner de
la personne et
cetera
21世紀後 の
はの土最大 の
を和 をし
たして 今 宇宙 や兵器 に使わ れ た科学 テクノジー は地球
の開ら新 繁栄 をえ
[Musique]
al ça c'est la série des jouets des des
robots qui ont été les plus chers à
l'époque ils étaient fabriqués par la
marque
Matsuda l'époque pour acheter un gamin
un robot comme ça il faut économiser
2000 balles 2000 francs français ou
quelque chose comme ça y a une var qui
s'appelle Machine Man qui est rouge et
ça été adugé par ce dans l'équivalent de
500000 francs
français vous remarquez quand j'appuie
sur le bouton ça change de
directionil quand j'appuie fa en fait
c'est les roues qui bougent à droite et
à gauche
c'est parti
[Musique]
oh une autre approche de l'économie
mis
nomche
deurournable dans l'industrie jouet
robot directeur de plusieurs mus de J fr
deirrouver les j de son enfance ilcié
deuire des rép de jouet des
[Musique]
années
durant les années 60 c'est dans un
quartier populaire de Toky que se
regroup toutes les petites usines de
jouet aujourd'hui il n'existe plus
qu'une seule fabrique de jouet
traditionnel c'est là que Monsieur KAG
passe s
[Musique]
commandes
hay
[Musique]
dozo
[Rires]
[Musique]
encore un autre
système inventé par les Japonais c'est
ce système derrière que vous voyez avec
les roues le jouet il touche un obstacle
il ne s'arrête pas il change de
direction il va dans un autre
obstacle regardez je metre ma main
voilà je metre ma main
voilà regardez c'est
[Musique]
magique toujours dans la veine de la
nostalgie une économie du jouet
d'occasion peut s'avérer très fructueuse
bonjour bienvenue à mand le royaume du
manga et de tout ce qui touche au monde
de l'animation japonaise nous sommes ici
en face du premier magasin de mandalake
qui a commencé il y a environ une
quinzaine d'années ici à vendre des
mangas d'occasion sur un petit 5 m² et
maintenant nous retrouvons face à ce
gigantesque magasin où on peut retrouver
absolument tous les genres de mangas
existant c'est assez immense et il faut
avoir un petit peu l'habitude pour s'y
retrouver il y a environ une vingtaine
de boutiques et chaque boutique
représente un genre particulier là on va
le voir dans la boutique de jouets la
boutique des jouets il y a environ une
dizaine d'années pour nos amis fans des
robots les robots les plus récents on
peut voir ici le très célèbre
[Musique]
goldorac donc là nous nous retrouvons
vraiment au centre nevralgique de
mandalake c'est là où tout débute c'est
que mandalak est basé sur la l'achat de
produits d'occasion des particuliers
pour ensuite les remettre en vitrine et
les propos à tous nos clients et là on
peut voir justement mon grand patron en
train de discuter avec des clients
particuliers pour le rachat de des
prochains produits qui seront en vente
dans les magasins très bientôt on y
[Musique]
va c'est le magasin des vieux jouets
c'estd des jouets d' d'après guerre et
jusqu'au années à peu près
80 our dans les robots restons dans les
[Musique]
robots voir ici les fameux
Transformers et nous poursuivons notre
petite visite au cœur de mandalake avec
notre prochaine invité j'ai nommé le
grand patron de mandalake Monsieur FO
[Musique]
allons-y to 画 を 心し た ん です ね画 に な と っ て
で 年間 ぐ画売画
ぱ
だ画専門忙く え これ が です ね 当時 ね 100円 と か これ 150円
し た ん です か ね か 150円 し た ん です けど も 僕 ら の
お小遣 が 1 日 5円 だっ た ん です ね 150っ
た から
1月間ずっと 何 も買わ で我慢ゃ いけ ない です ね とても そんな こと
そのえ子供 に は でき ませ ん でし た から やっぱり これ 夢 の 夢当
150円 の 買え なかっ た ん です けど も 今
僕や買
から古求め
は 感動 が 欲い ん ですそう いう 求め て さ高い
出される懸間 をし
てちこち ね僕 も に 価値求め て認め て社
[Musique]
買わけ
attardonsnous dans cet esprit de
nostalgie et retrouvons comme promis
monsieur Kar qui nous entraîne dans ses
entrepôts et nous explique pourquoi et
comment il est devenu
collectionneur
partons avec Monsieur dans les méandres
DEES entrepôts
pari les cons nous permettra peut-être
d'exumer les robots de sa
collection
min
[Rires]
r Z fr
po
robot
Rob robto s
Rob
robotent
finalement le robot ne serait pas un
objet technologique mais un objet
affectif
comment met-on l'affection en équation
[Musique]
scientifique les robot de ce genre n'ont
plus rien à voir avec ce qui était les
robots disons joué il y a 30 ans ici
nous avons des objets qui intègr d'une
part les progrès qu'a fait la robotique
dans ce domaine là et puis aussi les
progrès qu' fait l'intelligence
artificielle on va un petit peu donc
regarder les capacités d'attention en
fait par rapport à différents types
d'objets
c'est pas
forcément immédiat en fait le le robot
peut porter son attention sur certaines
choses et pas sur d'autres on va
regarder
ça on voir s'il
[Applaudissements]
l'approche
[Musique]
ement il a mordu la la
[Applaudissements]
fleur finalement quand on regarde un peu
l'histoire de la robotique il y a un
phénomène intéressant c'est que les
créateurs des différents robots
s'attaquent à des aspects assez
spécifiques de l'homme à chaque coup
c'est-à-dire qu'on va faire des robots
pour le remplacer éventuellement dans
des tâches répétitives parce que le le
robot peut être au moins aussi habile si
ce n'est plus habile que l'homme après
on va avoir une situation dans lequelle
on va se dire mais finalement la
différence clairement entre l'homme et
un robot ce serait l'intelligence
l'homme serait intelligent et pas le
robot et on va à partir de là avoir
toute une série
d'ordinateurs ou de programme
informatique dont le but va être de
copier ou de reproduire l'intelligence
humaine pendant un certain temps ça va
être grand grand de quête en fait de de
de ce genre de recherche jusqu'à ce
qu'on s'aperçoive en fait que bah
certains aspects de l'intelligence par
exemple sont pas si intéressants jouer
aux échecs que finalement on arrive à le
faire avec une machine ce qui nous amène
à nous à nous dire que finalement
l'intelligence c'est peut-être autre
chose c'est peut-être par exemple avoir
une conversation avec quelqu'un c'est
peut-être des aspects un peu différents
peut-être qu' y a une intelligence
émotionnelle donc petit à petit à
nouveau un glissement et tout d'un coup
on va avoir à nouveau des machines qui
vont alors peut-être donner l'impression
d'avoir des émotions qu'est-ce que ça
pourrait vouloir en fait qu'un robot de
ce genre soit capable de s'attacher à
son maître est-ce que ça ve dire qu'ils
ont une histoire commune le fait d'
capable de doter les robots d'une
histoire propre c'est aujourd'hui un des
grand grands enjeux de la recherche dans
ce
[Musique]
domaine
le but de notre recherche c'est que si
deux personnes achètent un robot de
loisir et que ces personnes élèvent ce
robot un contexte différent et bien
quand ell se retrouveront un an plus
tard les robots seront très différents
dans leur
comportement
[Musique]
17 années de recherche scientifique
permettrait donc à un chien de pousser
une balle ou à un robot de danser quelle
est la véritable motivation des
chercheurs il y a beaucoup de gens qui
discutent de des Poti fonctionnalité de
ces robots dans dans le futur à quoi ça
servira d'avoir un robot domestique ce
qui est intéressant je pense c'est de
considérer
sérieusement la possibilité d'avoir des
robots qui n'ont pas de fonctionnalité
de certain
[Musique]
manière et le rebau dans tout cela qu'en
pense-t-il cela fait presque un siècle
que l'homme se penche sur son cas mais
a-t-il le droit lui à la parole si tel
était le cas qu'aurait-il à nous
dire le robot qui rit il devrait rire
hein
[Musique]
j'espère regardez il rit après il s'en
va après là il va rigoler encore en plus
avec
[Applaudissements]
les si notre questionnement sur le robot
r dernier n'estce pas parce que
l'androïde a été conçu uniquement pour
nous permettre de vivre nos rêves
d'enfant comme une main tendu vers
l'avenir comme une balle lancée vers le
futur par exemple ici
avec sa
tête
comme une quête sans fin dans les
cartons de notre
[Musique]
enfance
y y
y